we can't believe it bts's jungkook is
showing off a
vibrant new look
a month after dyeing his hair blonde the
bts star posted a mirror selfie of his
new
wavy blue locks check out jungkook
hanging out in some
casual clothes showing off the blue do
from blonde to blue there's no doubt he
can rock just about any shade
and look dynamite
jungkook debuted his new tresses the day
after bts
absolutely slayed their mtv unplugged
concert special
making them the first korean act in
history to headline the show
[Music]
the most surprising moment of the night
when bts performed a cover of the
coldplay classic
fix you
[Applause]
but mtv unplugged is just one of the
many milestones bts has reached the past
few months
in december the group was named time
magazine's entertainer of the year
an accomplishment they credit to their
friendship and their fans
the bts army it's a sentiment the group
shared while speaking with
e.t in august so i want to say army
really
is our inspiration you know things are
tough for everybody you know everybody's
really going through hard times
but i think you know for army to have
this energy and show this drive it
really inspires us
bts is also making grammy history
becoming the first k-pop group
to break into the best pop duo group
performance category for their single
dynamite
dynamite brings some much needed energy
into the world
how did everything that's going on in
the world including with the pandemic
kind of
influence your new music you know 2020
has been truly a rough year for
many and there were many surprises
changes we felt like
desperate to be honest with you um we
needed
we thought we needed a breakthrough from
that so we focused on
what we can do the best and that was the
music
and the performance you know and we
tried to get energy
and we wanted to give the energy back to
the world so you know
things are simple the world needs the
positive explosion
and we came with dynamite and boom